Everywhere I ride you
create a little gang.
You attract young boys on bikes.
They surround you,
they call out to you.
Some throw rocks,
some aim them low
so it's just to get your
attention, some aim at you.
Most of them want to just
ride bikes with you.
What I found was that you
attract more attention,
but you're attracting the
good kind of attention.
You're attracting camaraderie,
you're attracting joy.
The problem for me was
every single ride
realizing that girls
were unable to do this.
This was the view of the girls.
They're watching me ride,
they're watching the joy,
they're watching the boys
ride, and they're not allowed.
And it's heartbreaking,
and it's... unfair.
What I started to look at was...
the question that
would come up is
does it even matter
whether girls ride bikes.
So girls can't ride, aren't
there bigger issues?
The bike was a key component of
our own women's rights
movement in the US.
And I started digging back
into our own history
of the Suffragettes
and what was the
reaction when US women,
when American women
started riding bikes.
You know, Susan B. Anthony,
one of the, you know...
the voices of that time, the
fact that she says that it was
"a tool that has done more
for emancipating women
than anything else in
the world", I mean...
that's astounding.
Much like the young
women in Afghanistan
that are now riding bikes.
I found out that there was a
Men's National Cycling Team.
No one I knew had ever
heard of such a thing.
Men and boys ride
everywhere, you see them...
everywhere, across the streets
it's the most common
mode of transportation.
But never girls.
But they're not, they're
never doing it for sports.
Cycling is not an Afghan sport.
Football and cricket
are the Afghan sports.
And so, I asked to
meet this young man.
It turns out he was a waiter
at a cafe that I had
gone to before.
And then the really
fascinating thing was
he found out that I rode bikes
and invited me to come for
a ride with the team.
Of course, I
immediately say yes.
Although I am a
little nervous about
riding on the Afghan highways.
Trucking, it's a trucking route.
You've got the big Pakistani
jingle trucks blowing by.
There's no rules of the road.
Most Afghans have not taken
a drivers license test.
And we meet at this
petrol station.
As we're all gathering,
you see boys starting to come
from different directions.
The coach arrived in his car.
And he's got his...
assistant with him.
A young woman, beautiful,
strong features.
She looks tough.
And he's furious.
"Why has nobody told me that
there's a foreign woman
coming to ride with
the men's team?
It's putting her at risk,
it's putting you at risk."
And he's like, in my
face, yelling at me.
And once he gets it
out of his system
'cause that very kind of
Afghan to just get it out,
then he shakes my hand,
he says, "welcome."
( audience laughter )
Okay...
"Why are you here?"
And I said, "well, I ride bikes.
I used to be a sports
trainer in a prior life.
And I'm a mountain biker.
And the boys, you know, invited
me to come and ride with them.
I didn't mean any offense,
they didn't tell me
anything about you.
And, who is this
woman with you?"
And he says, "well, this is
Mariam. She's my assistant,
but she's also on the Afghan
National Women's team."
I'm like, "women's team...
How did this come to be?
I've been looking for
women for three years.
I've never met one family that
would allow their
girl to ride a bike.
Or that... any girl I've
ever met or
woman who has
ridden a bike."
And he said that when he
started the men's team,
which is pre-Taliban time.
And then had to stop because
of the Taliban time,
he had wanted to
start a girls' team.
He didn't see any reason not to.
And he started with
his own daughters.
As is always the case, it's you
know, that family connection.
He wanted his girls to
experience the joy of riding.
I asked if I could
meet the team.
Of course, he allowed and
I met with the girls.
And said, "how can I help?
I mean, this...
we are kinda coming full
circle in my journey here.
Like, how do I help support
these young women?"
This is exactly what I
had always hoped was that
we'd find a way that we
could normalize bikes
so that we could get girls
bikes to get to schools.
And so that we could reduce
the gender violence.
So that when girls are
walking the gauntlet
in an urban environment
where they're
getting acid thrown at them,
where they're kidnapped,
where there's rocks thrown,
where they're being attacked,
we can give them a
really simple tool.
When they're in rural areas
and can't access medical care
or can't access a school
they have the ability to
travel a greater distance.
And we need, then we
need fewer resources,
we don't need as many schools
if we can bring more
people to them.
Then we can spend that
money on more teachers.